so thanks for inviting me so I'm going
to talk about how we are using machine
learning and optimization to do
advertising at LinkedIn and so before I
begin this is more a applied talk I'm
not going to talk about new methods I'm
going to talk about how you can take all
the awesome academic methods that are
out there and apply it to a industrial
application with success right so here
is an example of how we do ad word off
where ads get shown at LinkedIn so if
you go to the LinkedIn front page this
is an example of a display ads that is
shown to users based on their
professional identity and other
targeting attributes there is another
example where we store show ads within
the stream the network update stream as
we call it so there are many other
places if you go to profile pages you
see ads if you go to search pages you
see ads ads are ubiquitous as in any
other web centric company right so here
is a rough flow of how the advertising
system works again I've oversimplified
the process but still it gives you a
high-level idea so we get an ad request
when a user is visiting some page and
again with the ad request comes all the
information about the user
like what region they are from what is
the age of the user where are where is
this request coming from what is the
size of the real estate where the ad has
to be placed and so on and so forth
this goes to the ad server who's and the
ad server targa filters out a bunch of
campaigns based on some targeting
criteria that are usually specified by
the advertiser so the advertiser might
say don't show my ads except for
facebook engineers in Silicon Valley
right if you are Google you might do
that right I just want to target
Facebook engineers right and then you
know we are not going to show you any
other ads except for Facebook engineers
right if an ad has been seen by a member
multiple times we don't want to prolong
their
any further so we stopped showing that
we also do things like budget pacing I'm
not going to go into that but that's
again a more technical thing once that
is all done then we send the ads to a
module which selects the format in which
the act should be displayed so this is
more the look and feel of the ad right
should I write the text in bold should
the color of the ad be blue or red and
so on and so forth right and it does
make a difference how you present these
ads to users right and then finally it
goes to a response prediction engine and
the response prediction engine predicts
click-through rates when an ad is going
to be shown to a particular member and
once that is done we sort the ads by bit
time CTR our expected revenue and you
know that's how the ad gets displayed
and if a user clicks on the ad which is
not very often but they do click on the
ads sometimes that's how our bills get
paid then we kind of run an auction and
it's a second price auction the winner
pays the minimum price required to in
the auction right so that's the whole
flow so I'm going to talk about the
response prediction parts in this stock
right and so that two different places
where we use response prediction one is
to select the right format to show the
ad to the user the look and feel so we
have web devs that create a bunch of
formats like a few tens or 20 those you
know different look and feel and the
goal of machine learning here is to
figure out what is the best format to
show to each user right that's one
problem once we have selected the format
then the goal is again to use response
prediction to pick up the top ads to be
ranked by expected revenue so let's
start with the warm-up exercise of how
we select the right ad formats
automatically through machine learning
right so we have a different we have a
bunch of page types so it could be home
page it could be profile page it could
be search page and so on so forth so a
bunch of page type and for each page
type you have a bunch of admissible
formats that have been created by the
web
right and again a simple approach would
be you know you can't clicks you count
views for every format in it for every
single page type and then you rank the
format's by the click-through rate right
clicks over this is a very simplistic
approach okay
so this doesn't work why what happens if
there is a new format that gets
introduced into the system how do you
onboard a new format how do you avoid
starvation of an old format that have
been prematurely terminated right maybe
the user did not click on the ad for the
first four times it was shown and so the
click-through rate is zero that doesn't
mean that the format is bad it was just
it had an unlucky streak to begin with
right so how do you mitigate these
issues so this is also known as the
Explorer exploit dilemma in the machine
learning and statistics literature if
you are familiar with that of course you
know what I'm talking about but if
you're not familiar with that I'm just
going to do some small animation and
show you right so imagine there are four
different formats that are in the system
and again those are the statistics that
we have accumulated for these formats
you'll notice the last one is the one
that just got into the system and we
have some historical data to guess that
the CTR of that is something like that
right and oh sorry I think the previous
slide had different typos you know the
click-through rate should be 2.5 and so
on so forth so I'm pologize for that
right so suppose you have this scenario
now how do you decide what protraction
of traffic to allocate to each of these
formats right so if you take a greedy
approach you would of course decide that
100% of the traffic should be allocated
to format 3 and the other should be
terminated immediately right but again
as you see that's not the right approach
because the other formats do not have
enough data for us to be making such a
decision so early on right so you might
say okay well why don't we randomly
allocate equal amounts to all format now
that is yes that is democratic but
democracy don't work very well
especially when your algorithms so
that's highly suboptimal so that's not
going to work and so something in
between is what works right so
for instance you know if you do
something like a softmax instead of a
max right so I locate traffic
proportional to your current CTR
estimate maybe perhaps tempered by some
temperature and so on and so forth that
may give you a better allocation right
it helps you exploit format that are
known to be good but it also helps you
explore formats that are potentially
good right and that is how you maximize
your overall performance of the system
right so there are many other there are
many explore explored schemes in the
literature I'm not going to go through
that so what we do is we evaluate
several explore explored schemes by
doing offline replay analysis and again
this is something that was done by John
so we use that heavily we test a series
of explore x-cart schemes and then we
launch the ones that look promising in
offline analysis and you know for this
application
you know most of the usual Explorer
exploit schemes seem to be working quite
well for us it does make a difference as
to how quickly you have it your CTRs if
you have many new formats coming in the
system regularly in our case we don't
get many new formats coming to our
system very quickly so for us updating
the CTRs on a daily basis is ok so this
was just a warm-up exercise and you know
that the format selection problem was an
easy one you have a small number of
formats we tried running algorithms to
personalize format based on gender geo
that doesn't matter what really matters
is the size of the real estate and where
you are showing the ad that is the most
important characteristics in this
problem others did not matter too much
so in some sense it's an easy problem ok
so now let's come to how we will
estimate the CTR of ads once you have
selected the right format you have to
fill up those slots with the best ads so
you still have to compute the
click-through rates when an ad is shown
to a user and here member or user
attributes do matter quite a bit you
have to personalize the estimates of the
CTR otherwise you don't do a good job
right so it is important to estimate CTR
for this particular application at more
granular resolutions then what we are
doing for the forward selection
right so you have to create more
segments maybe based on users industry
based on users age education what they
have done in the past which company they
worked for which company they move to
and so on and so forth lot of
information plus we have all the
behavioral data as well right what they
have been doing on the front page what
they have been reading whose profiles
they have been poking who's been poking
at their profile and so on so forth it's
a lot of information alright so how do
you use all that information which we
have about users both the identity and
the behavioral data and kind of do a
good job of personalizing these CTR
estimates right so that's what we want
to do and again you know this is the
usual machine learning problem so if you
choose too few segments then you fail to
personalize so you have more bias in
your estimates of course if you choose
too many then you end up in data set
into data sparsity and you have high
variance like for instance if you chop
your data into very small pieces then
most of the segments will have zero
cliques right and again it's just a
matter it's a matter not of
distinguishing 0 over 5 from 0 over 50
from 0 or 5 million right that's really
the crux of the problem so in order to
solve that problem you have to pool data
by segments to mitigate data sparsity
right and here is an example right so if
you want to estimate the CTR of an ad ID
77 on a profile page for a user from
Palo Alto you may not have an update all
right this ad may have been shown only
five times and you observe no clicks so
that's not going to help you get
reliable CTR estimates so what you may
want to do is you might want to
piggyback on the overall TR for visits
on the profile page or you might think
he back on the overall CTR for users
from Palo Alto these are some examples
of features if you will which you can
construct to kind of come up with a good
estimate or reliable estimate for CTR on
that on that particular cell right and
again there are many different ways of
doing this polling business in an
effective way in machine learning you
can use many techniques decision trees
random forests gradient boosters
decision tree but we decided to use
logistic regression right and again
there is no particular reason why you
should use or you should not leave
logistic regression it was just a matter
of convenience and logistic regression
these class of problems have shown have
been shown to work very well in practice
right so that's the only reason but the
principles I'm going to describe later
on in the talk could be applied to other
models as well there is no reason why
you can't apply the same principle which
I am talking about even if you're doing
a decision tree for instance right ok so
again for those of you don't know what
the logistic regression is this is not
for machine learning trade machine
learners so suppose you're trying to fit
a logistic regression in two dimensions
and again both these dimensions are
continuous Gaussian all that stuff you
have some historical data in these two
dimensions some of them are positive
some of them are negative so what
logistic regression does is it finds the
best line that separates the positives
from the negative right and then if you
have a new point and you want to predict
the probability of a click you look at
the distance of this point from the best
fitting line and read the probability
from that sigmoid function right so
that's essentially at a high level
that's what logistic regression is now
you know you can kind of look at what
the logistic regression would look like
mathematically right so your features
available for users again based on all
their identity and behavioral data we
have features that we extract from the
AdWords ad itself like all the keywords
all the text you write when you are
actually submitting the ads to our
system we also have information about
the context in which the ad has been
shown like what kind of page is that
being shown on what position is the ad
being shown on what device is the ad
being shown on is it mobile or is it
desktop and so on and so forth right all
right so I here denotes the user ID J
here denotes the ad ID and K here
denotes the context ID right and we have
historical data that gives you responses
when ad J have been shown to user I on
context K right we have tons and tons of
data right so what logistic regression
does is it assume that this is a
Bernoulli model that is a coin toss
experiment with probability pIJ K and
then on the log art scale it assumed
that this probability could be the log
arts could be expressed as a linear
function of all these features which I
talked about right so this is what we
call the cold start component right so
these are this component is only a
function of features which
you can extract for users add and
context right and this is something
which can be trained in terms of
historical data it does not change very
rapidly we kind of train this component
once a week and then the second
component is what we call the warm start
component also called the random effects
in statistics if you are familiar with
that right so this component is not good
enough to capture all idiosyncrasies of
an ad right so if you can do a very good
job of each or engineering and extract
everything about the ad then this
component would not be needed but
unfortunately that is very hard to do so
despite the despite of however well you
do in this particular component you
still would have some residual
idiosyncrasies that are not explained by
this particular component and that is
what this component is capturing right
so J here is the ID ID so you are
building a per ad adjustment on top of
this cold-start component which is
explaining the probabilities using just
the feature vectors for ads users and
contexts okay so this is the cold-start
component the stable component this is
the warm start component which is
capturing what the residual is
idiosyncracies okay okay right and so
model training right so the cold start
again as I said is trained on large
amounts of historical data billions of
observation thousands of features the
training is done on a regular vanilla
MapReduce framework we did not create
any new infrastructure for doing that
and I am going to explain how we do that
the warm start once we have trained the
cold start the warm start component is
used as an offset and then we fit as
independent logistic regression for
every single ad ID right so once you
freeze the forms call start component
you can actually create an independent
logistic regression for every ad and
just kind of run them in peril right so
again a very easy thing to do on Map
Reduce all right so the computations
here are rather trivial because of the
way we do it right so the second
component is rather easy you can easily
paralyzed on MapReduce now I'm going to
talk about how we paralyze the first
component on MapReduce right that's not
so obvious okay so in order to do that
we use
so I've already gone through this I'm
not going to go through the Map Reduce
slide you spend one hour explaining
MapReduce
so done all right so this is how one
could think about doing it right so a
naive approach would be you partition
your data into multiple components at
random you fit a separate logistic
regression to each component and you
average the result right that's a naive
approach now that's okay but it is not
guaranteed to converge to the global
solution which you will get if you had
run the algorithm on the entire data set
right so fortunately there is there is
an algorithm which has been popularized
by Stephen Boyd at Stanford called the
ad mm algorithm right so what the
algorithm does is it does a scatter and
gather approach of computing things but
it sets up constraints and the
constraints are every partitions
estimate has to be constrained to be
equal to the global estimate right so
when you're doing this computation you
have a bunch of loads small logistic
regressions you get independent
estimates from these logistic regression
but we kind of add a constraint on top
of that which says that every single
logistic regression should be equal to
the global consensus estimate right so
you can cast it as an optimization
problem and if you can solve this
optimization problem which actually
could be done in a scatter and gather
approach I'm going to show you in a
minute you are guaranteed to converge to
the global optimum if you kind of do if
you kind of do a lot of iterations okay
so this is how it works if you draw a
picture right so your big data your
partition things you do independent
logistic regression in each of these
boxes then you do some consensus
computation which is driven by the
constraints and then you kind of pass
back information which you got from the
first iteration to the partitions again
redo a computation and then you keep
doing it until you converge right so
again you can write down the
optimization as follows right so this is
the logistic regression or partition
subject to this constraint right beta
equals to beta all right this is exactly
what a DMM does and for the l2
regression this is what the equations
look like so essentially in every box
you are doing local regression shrunk
towards the best global estimate you
have so far and then once you get the
local estimates you kind of do a
consensus estimate and again pass it by
for the next iteration right so it's a
scatter and the other approach no
communication between the processors at
all okay okay and so we didn't we made
some changes to the ad mm algorithm so
first of all initialization is very
important for ad mm if you initialize
your estimate by just doing this nice
scatter and gather approach and doing
the consensus estimate that improves the
convergence a lot secondly the step size
which you have an ad mm that has to be
selected carefully so if you make it
adaptive that also helps convergence
quite a bit in fact in our experiment we
saw that these two simple optimization
reduce training time from 10 hours to 2
hours and here is a curve which kind of
shows this ok so so this is how we do
this now the next thing is how do you do
explore exploit in this particular
scenario when you know just dig
regressions again the idea is very
simple so this is the cold start line
and then for every ad we have a warm
start right and we don't add any
statistical uncertainty in the cold
start part because we assume that that
component has been trained on tons of
data there is not much statistical
variability going on here most of the
statistical variation is going on in the
warm start part where we run a per ad
model right so if this is the model and
if so so what what you do is for every
bomb start component you have a
posterior distribution and when you're
serving the ad you draw a random number
from that which is essentially drawing a
random line for the second component and
I add that and kind of starts loading
the alright so that's how you do the
cold start component it's also called
Thompson sampling in the literature
right so I'm going to show you so for
the sake of showing results I'm going to
kind of have I'm going to use some names
here so laser this is going to be the
logistic regression which we ran without
the Thompson sampling scheme I just
described so it isn't constant sampling
is nothing but just adding some jitter
to your estimate that's all it is right
and the jittering is done based on the
posterior distribution for every ad
right and then laser is the logistic
regression which we do by using this
jittering or Explorer exploit as I
described right so let me show you some
results so these are some results from
offline analysis so control here is the
model that LinkedIn was running
dear I can't describe what that model is
I can describe it offline maybe but I
don't have time to describe what that
was cold only is so this is a model
which was run without using any ad
specific adjustment just the feature
based adjustment and this is the model
which we used both the feature based
adjustment as well as the ad based
adjustment and you can see that if you
look at the AUC and ROC curves of course
these two are better than the others
these are some results which we obtained
from online experiment right so whenever
you are running these tests you always
tend to over predict because you're
selecting the best out of a bunch of
things and so you know my definition
there is selection bias and you tend to
over predict your performance right so
one good measure of accuracy is how much
your model is over predicting for
different ads or different campaigns
right so one here our campaigns where we
have very little data eight here our
campaigns where we have collected a lot
of data and as you can see the over
prediction increases as you go from the
campaigns with scarce data to campaigns
with a lot of data which is expected but
the amount of our prediction is much
less with the new kind with a new class
of model which I described compared to
the control model that LinkedIn was
running right so this is again all
results which we are obtaining from
online tests that are running in the
system I can't reveal the lift numbers
which we got in production but again
here is an example which shows you the
eCPM lift or the revenue lift per
impression which we get by running these
models in production systems right so
this is zero percent and you can
interpret it in any way you like but at
least what this is showing you is there
is a consistent improvement in
performance every day when we run this
test right so this test was done for six
months and now the whole system is kind
of running based on this system the old
the old system is all deprecated now
this is the new system which is running
at LinkedIn today
okay that's a weekend or we get traffic
from France and they're not doing very
well in France okay so here is another
plot which I want to show sorry there is
one line that there is one line with a
different color which is not appearing
due to the form okay so I wanted to show
this plot to show the difference between
the explore exploit bucket and the
exploit only bucket so what happens is
if you look at the exploit only bucket
where there is no jittering going on
then you see a consistent lift for all
types of campaigns campaigns with have
little data and campaigns which have
very high data but if you look at the
other bucket which is this one you see a
huge loss in revenue for these buckets
but as you go up you see a big
improvement in these buckets and that is
expected because when you are doing
jittering for ads that are very new you
don't have an update or you don't have
good estimate you are going to
overestimate the city and you are going
to select the wrong ads more often but
that helps you generate learning data
which is used by this particular model
to do a good job right so again I think
this was a subtle point I can't explain
it without the picture it is very
difficult but there are some subtleties
going on when you do explore exploit
versus when you don't do explore exploit
okay so to summarize the main point was
the main point I want to make here is
reducing the dimension through X
logistic regression and coupling it with
an Explorer exploit scheme like Thompson
sampling looks like an effective
mechanism to solve response prediction
problem in computational advertising if
you partition the model component as
call start which is based purely on
features and warm start which is
capturing residual idiosyncrasies at the
ad level and campaign level and that's
an effective mechanism to scale your
computation you can do the first
computation at very coarse granularity
and you
do the second computation very fast
within few hours so that's a very good
way of scaling computations and even if
you use a DMM with a few modification it
is an effective model training strategy
for large data with high dimensionality
and again these methods have been
working pretty well for us in LinkedIn
advertising it has provided significant
improvement so far these are my
collaborators by the way this picture is
not what he looks like so current work
we are investigating spark and various
other fitting algorithms to scale up the
ad mm algorithm even further and we have
obtained some promising results ad mmm
still looks good on our data sets we are
spending a lot of time working on how to
do stream advertising right so stream
advertising is not all about predicting
click-through rates you have to predict
click-through rates you have to predict
share rates you to predict likes you
have to predict comments and if you
combine these estimates to come up with
a good measure of what user engagement
means a highly very challenging problem
filtering low quality ads is very
important on the stream because you know
if you're seeing your friends update and
then suddenly you see a bad ad you stop
see your friend updates as well and stop
coming to Lincoln so we have to be very
careful when you're injecting ads within
organic content right and that's why
it's a hard problem so that's something
that you're working on we are also
working on stream recommendations how do
you how do you recommend updates on your
stream right if you have different kinds
of updates you know job anniversary from
your friends something that has been
published by the company you follow
something that have been published by
the influencers you follow something
that your friends shared on the network
how do you take all that content and the
advertising which we want to inject and
do a holistic job of providing a good
stream to the user that's again a very
challenging problem when you're working
on that right now finally we are
investing a lot in building large scale
machine learning infrastructure at
LinkedIn you know similar to the methods
I just described that is going to that
is powering a lot of other
recommendation problems we have on
LinkedIn like Jim for instance jobs you
may like people you may like and so on
and so forth groups you may like a lot
of other recommend
problems as well right and so finally we
are hiring you know we have slots for
shameless plug but yes this is a good
opportunity if you are interested in
this kind of work taking cutting edge
machine learning work and putting this
into production and making a difference
to real-life application